one of the interesting things about the
book of psalms
being probably in many cases 2500 years
old
how they speak about anxiety and
in that collection of the literary genre
that you find in the book of psalms
the greatest the largest collection
are laments in other words their
worries about what is about to come
but one of the interesting things about
that literary genre
is that it moves from worry to hope
in all of the laments of the psalter
with the exception of one you end
or finish with a word of hope
that as you mentioned with the rise
and the fall of things in the movement
of life
and for the psalmist that is
god but for for others it may be
the higher power you know and if there
is no god and if there is no higher
power then what
was hope then based on um
i don't think that it's based on our
human abilities alone okay
because our human abilities
are dependent upon the movement of
divinity within us and that's
part of the the the great mystery i
think of human life
is that we have all have something of
the infinite within us
while we live a very finite life
sorry would you say that that it's
in the psalms it's the individual
anxiety
and the godhead is the fact that as a
species
we collaborate and work together
that's a bit of a difficult question to
answer in a broad way because
not all the psalms are individuals you
know you have
what are called communal laments social
lament as well yes
and social anxiety yes because we are
not making that distinction yet in our
discussion
individual anxiety is a physiological
response
yes social anxiety is influenced by
other individual responses yes and that
those mechanisms are not well understood
if i understand correctly
and that if if you buy that mystery that
you hold dear
you mean that then i would buy into your
mystery i wouldn't buy into all your
other um you called them
as a concept that seems to be tractable
by science and by literature